Well,
I started out,
I was the first gang specialist about
state of Texas.
My job was to essentially go into youth
prisons and Cellos,
young early adult prisons and deal with
the gang phenomenon that happened in the
nineties.
Job was to negotiate peace in those
environments and then furloughs,
young man out and allow them to go back
to the neighborhoods and top with your
ogs and their leaders to ask them to
give them free passage back into their
world.
And you know in this culture is,
it's less now.
It's less gang.
It's more a identity with whatever,
whatever area,
whatever neighborhood,
whatever scenario that you.
Again,
you identify with that so that becomes
your protection.
It becomes your identity,
becomes your way of life.
So someone has to figure out how to go
through that system and say,
let's get reality from those false
identities,
those false and so,
but you gotta be careful because no
matter if it's false or not,
if someone believes that they'll die for
it,
they'll kill for their live for.
So you have to know how to use whatever
influence you have to bring about a
different perspective.
Man,
I'm telling,
tell you one,
once I did a a gang negotiation with the
area and brotherhood,
right?
The arrogant nation and Nazis and when
they gathered,
they all had to affirm their belief
system and it was so interested in the
guy.
He looked around his group and he said,
we hate blacks and we hate,
we hate you.
And he looked at me.
He said,
but not you,
sir.
We don't,
we don't feel like that about you.
I said,
thank you man,
because what I realized what he said to
me was,
man,
we need you right man.
So let's do this.
This,
this is not a speech that's not
necessarily interest.
And uh,
and that guy became one of the leaders
of this,
your Emoji counsel that we did in the
prison,
which is a unity council.
But the point I'm making is,
is that enemies calm when there is true
violation,
not true rhetoric.
The rhetoric don't make enemies,
man.
It's just,
you know,
you gotta go past that.
You know,
that there's some stuff that I promised
you I will not say on camera that me and
my wife had all has argued about it and
you would think,
boy,
they are enemies.
No,
they just,
she didn't want to get on TV and I don't
want to,
you know,
and it just got out of her hand.
So sometimes you have to go beyond the
rhetoric so you can see the real and
they're so,
so you got to classify a person with
enemy,
with their intent,
with that consistent behavior.
And it's,
it's a whole,
you know,
it's a whole broad range when you try to
deal like that.
And so you have to be very,
very,
very careful when you're doing it
because you never know who you're going
to need on many,
many,
many sides.
So that's how I see enemy.
So you right about that.
It's very rather than my spirit,
I would say,
as an enemy because when you can't do
the inner work,
good,
I do,
you will be.
You will really limit your influence and
limit your access if you thought in
those terms.
So,
uh,
you know,
I did work with Paul Ryan,
he was doing the poverty tool,
uh,
on,
with,
with someone with a mentor,
my mentor,
Bob Woodson,
and it was called what works and why,
and he was going around and see what
really works and he had this idea called
a better way forward.
And so they came to Dallas.
I had no knowledge of him.
He came to Dallas to come see my work
and one of his first trips when he
became speaker of the house was I do a
big celebration every mlk.
They've where outbrain healers from all
over the city of Dallas then,
but now all over the nation,
they came together,
suggests,
affirmed what we were doing and to read,
you know,
revisit where we were.
One of his first trips,
he came there and was that strictly
listened.
He stayed for a few hours just listening
to everyone and talking in,
in there in that space.
And it was so interesting how the
perception was not the reality,
because most people who work in
neighborhoods,
you know,
they have a philosophy that will say it
own,
lean it on lean toward where you are
fall.
But he was as comfortable in that moment
as I was when he brought us up to talk
to a group of guys who are
conservatives.
And uh,
we,
we did a deal at the American Enterprise
Institute and other places where we were
just trying to share our ideas.
And what we saw when we started
realizing is there's not a lot of
separation and the separation is very
small.
And so,
um,
we began to just work in that in that
sense.
Yeah.
You know,
perspective comes from where you are.
I never forget when Paul and I first
met,
I was saying,
what is he,
what is he trying to gain from this?
And um,
and,
and his direct answer was inflammation.
I don't know what I don't know.
So teach,
show me what it means to be in this
moment.
And then I'm going to show you who I am.
And then he said something that's very
powerful.
He said,
Omar,
there are people who are poised to help
you,
that you wouldn't,
you wouldn't meet,
but I won't.
I want to introduce you to this world.
And I'm skeptical because I'm working in
the streets saying right,
anybody who won't help me,
I pretty much know and I was wrong.
So we met at a vulnerable place where we
both could learn.
And the power of that relationship is
that we didn't have to start hiding from
real issues to work together.
Uh,
uh,
Charles Koch says something that was so
strong to me.
He said,
what do we fiercely agree upon?
And less work like hell to make it
happen.
Sounds like that.
Where do we fiercely agree up also there
we really agreed that everyone wants to
be a citizen.
Yeah.
Do we really agreed that that poverty
should not be the destination.
It could be a transportation,
but yet do we really agree that,
that anyone can transform the transform
transformation?
Yeah.
Redemption yet.
So we just started figuring out what we
agree upon and it was easy to have real
relationship.
So Paul then for me,
it was not political,
it was,
it was real.
And then when we had real disagreements,
they were coming from a pure place.
Paul,
I'm agree with his policy.
He said,
yeah,
well my scoop it and we didn't have any
heartburn.
We had true,
uh,
ideas that could,
that could play out in the theater ideas
and see what happens.
But,
but,
but the goal was bigger than the roles
it was not us trying to figure this
thing out.
So it stopped being this conversational
priests.
We figuring out how we played a game
with each other.
It started really being,
do we do,
do we add value to each other in all we
solving things that other people run a
way from and this in this environment of
us versus them,
right?
Versus left red vs blue,
a blue,
uh,
you know,
all of those things create the most,
um,
echo chamber life that you can have.
And it is,
it's going to have major consequences
when you really have to solve deep
problems.
You cannot solve problems that way.
That's it.
That's insane.
You can't do that.